foreign
we've had dozens of iterations of the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles over the
decades ranging from the lighthearted
monster the weak romp of the 80s and 90s
2003's gritty comic accurate Love Letter
to Eastman and Laird's original run in
Mirage Comics the 2012 series is heavy
focus on modernizing the campiness of
the classic show and Rise of the TMNT
spectacularly animated tale of family
and finding your place in the world
let's not also forget the classic
quadrilogy that did a little bit of
everything and uh
the ones with scab cop Casey but no TMNT
take thus far has quite perfected that
teenage mutant element like 2023's
mutant Mayhem when this project was
initially pitched with a strong focus on
that teenage element of the team I
shuddered at the thought of a cringy
wildly out of touch take on Zoomer
Turtles written by 50 year olds forcing
them to say slang like YOLO swag hashtag
fidget spinner memes 420 Blaze it like
everything you remember teen sang in
like 2010 because they always get to
these things a decade late well that was
an epic fail
typically the turtles are either written
to sound like Surfers skater dudes and
acceptably outdated paradoxically
Timeless vernacular or they're written
so neutrally that you start to forget
their teenagers at all and just start to
think of them as like short 28 year olds
but mutant Mayhem pulled off what it set
out to do and portrayed the turtles as
believable likable realistic 15 year
olds in every way the voice cast
consisting of Nicholas Cantu Micah Abby
Brady noon and Shimon Brown Jr are all
talented experienced voice actors who
also happen to be teenagers look at all
their previous roles
this casting Choice was what got me
really excited for the movie because
they didn't cast Tom Holland Jaden Smith
or some other young famous dork that
clams up behind a microphone instead of
being in their element on camera this
cast was chosen because God damn it
they're good voice actors and they sound
the right age not because they're big
names to put on a poster
that was reserved for the rest of the
mutants who had three lines of dialogue
each but I can live with that weirdly
this isn't the first Ninja Turtles thing
that John Cena's voice acted in I also
think it was a smart decision to cast
these guys as the main four so that they
could be a regular cast for the upcoming
TV series spin-off from this film I
wonder if any of these other ones will
follow along with that like Mondo gecko
is getting recast for that cartoon
surely Paul Rudd is expensive now my
sister is 16 years old and I was born
after the DVD player was invented so I'd
like to think I know what people this
age talk like and one of the highlights
of the movie is just how naturalistic
and fast-paced the dialogue between
Brothers sounds humans are the demons
come of the earth
and hey I know that's objectively
prejudiced but that's what Dad taught us
they're always relating their
experiences and surroundings to pop
culture because that's the way they got
to know the world around them and they
throw casual barbs at each other the way
I remember joking with my friends in
high school I was the Leonardo everyone
ganged up on me while I winced off into
the distance fantasizing about murder
with a samurai sword literally me and
the way they stumble over each other in
dialogue and effortlessly crack constant
rapid fire jokes just makes me want to
watch the movie over and over again to
catch every blink and you'll miss it
quip
apparently a lot of the dialogue between
the turtles was improvised when they
recorded together in the same room and
massive portions of the script were
Rewritten to fit their banter more
organically they'd be like what did you
just say Riz use that in the movie
explain it to me and then let's use the
chemistry really shines through in the
performances and serves as a perfect
example of how voice acting is a unique
and challenging form of acting in itself
but also how beneficial it can be to let
the cast bounce off of each other
instead of recording separately normally
I'm pretty bored by the idea of April
O'Neil being a teenager since we've
gotten nothing but that for the last
decade and I do miss her being like a
big sister to them but this is the first
time that I really genuinely felt like
she was the same age as them I think
this is the first time I've Loved
teenage April because her friendship and
interactions with the brothers feels so
lifelike
it felt like I was seeing not a normal
girl in four quirky cartoon monsters but
five teenagers hanging out just four of
them happen to be anthropomorphic
reptile martial artists it's not a fresh
new take on the character since it
borrows so heavily from the previous two
iterations but it was executed so well
that it feels like a new take if it was
always handled this well I wouldn't care
about teenage April anymore
I do wish they'd stop riding one or more
of the turtles having a crush on her all
right we've had horny pervert Mikey
strung along hopeless incel Donnie and a
Leo that's destined for the friend zone
is Raf next on the list
oh wait no no we got him covered okay
can we be done with that now no more
inter-species Awkward failed Romance
it's okay to keep it in your fan art and
your fan fix we all have our crack ships
I support that I think that's fine but
please stop making it Cannon thankfully
the series where the turtles don't have
reptilian sexual tension is finally
compiled into a respectable DVD box set
I remember when I was a kid and this
show was only available in three episode
discs that were maddeningly hard to find
and collecting it would have been a
massive undertaking since the show has
over a hundred episodes
tell you what turtle fans I'll be giving
away a copy of this box set for free all
you have to do is subscribe and tell me
in the comments below what your favorite
Ninja Turtles moment is from either the
movies the comics or the series and I'll
pick one lucky winner to get the entire
series on DVD and the Turtles Forever
movie this time I'm not technically
breaking State gambling laws with this
giveaway I'll announce the winner on
Twitter and Instagram in about two weeks
so see you then Splinter learn Ninjutsu
via training videos and YouTube
tutorials this time and somehow I hate
it less than book I found in a storm
drain I do wish we could bring back
hamoto Yoshi's pet rat studying his
moves because I thought that was
adorable but I can understand dialing it
back because the backstory can get
convoluted the worst version of the
origin story is ironically the original
Mirage book Hamato Yoshi was in love
triangle the Roku Noggin Tang Shen and
Nagi abuse Tang Shen so Yoshi killed
Nagi but nagi's brother orokusaki vowed
revenge and killed Tang Shane and homato
Yoshi and then Daredevil's origin yeah
you can simplify down I'm just glad
we're not permanently handcuffed to
Splinter being Hamato Yoshi transformed
into a rat like the three of the
cartoons and the ibw books
it's a cool take but I don't want it to
be the default origin and I'm open to
changing it around each time in six
years Splinter went from being a parody
of Jackie Chan to being played by Jackie
Chan the other thing to love about this
movie is the visual style that evokes
the sketchy look of a teenager's
notebook doodles characters have odd
proportions asymmetrical faces and
exaggerated Silhouettes objects are
never 100 perfectly square or round the
world and characters have these scratchy
outlines and colors that look like they
were done with markers and crayons
the visual style is so beautifully full
of imperfections that it takes you into
the mind of a kid just learning to draw
and the grimy ragged world is so
detailed in its messiness that it
becomes immensely appealing to look at I
could stare at any random frame of this
movie and see something new every time I
look at it it
3D accentuated with 2D style as
spider-verse taken in a new direction
that avoids being derivative and instead
looks wholly original
somehow the characters look like
claymation when they're having these
relaxed dialogue scenes with shaky
camera movements and spare editing but
the action scenes become highly
energetic and dynamic spectacle with
smooth motions and complex choreography
I don't think it quite lived up to the
action scenes from Rise of the TMNT but
it didn't disappoint me either in the
upcoming series and hopefully sequel can
still get us closer to that goal post
all of this action was of course greatly
improved by the music I never thought
we'd get a Ninja Turtles movie scored by
Nine Inch Nails but it works so well I
hope Trent rezner and Atticus Ross come
back for the series in the sequel since
they've worked together before on other
series like Watchmen time will have to
tell also these song titles are
hilarious
found the story to be like a better
thematic execution of TMNT Out of the
Shadows the movie not the game or the
green team are desperate to fit into the
human world and be accepted despite this
whole situation except instead of some
half-bake plot about becoming human they
decide the best path to acceptance is to
be seen as Heroes after clearing New
York of crime from a mysterious boss
pulling off technology heists it's cool
to see them fully Embrace their
superhero side instead of doing that
kind of consequently during more
personal matters
this time they're out there looking for
fights instead of it coming to them I
appreciate how active they are as
protagonists because of it usually
they're reluctant Heroes the story plays
things relatively straight and safe but
I had so much fun with it that I was
fine with it being on the conventional
side the 2007 movie tried to get more
complicated and ended up being riddled
with plot holes I hope we can get back
to that level of ambition with a more
solid execution in the sequel to this
big swings work for spider-verse
Superfly the movie's main villain is
simultaneously a brand new character and
a bit of a send-up of Stockman fly from
the 80s series and I was surprised at
how Ice Cube managed to really shine in
this role or range of Charisma that make
you understand why these mutants see him
as a leader and a grim ferociousness
that kept him threatening enough you'd
also understand why they fall in line
with his dastardly plans
I love this villain and I wouldn't mind
him showing up again in future TMNT
projects as another alternative to the
usual Shredder or crying slash utrom's
Shenanigans TMNT has a lot of good
villains I haven't heard great things
about preacher but otherwise Seth Rogen
is three for four on producing cool
comic book adaptations this one needs to
be identical to the comic this one needs
to be nothing like the comic this one
can be sort of the super bad of
superhero movies
teen comedy where the characters feel
like real teenagers and the coming of
age feels more earned for it the ending
is also a completely unique direction
for the TMNT that hasn't really been
attempted before attempted well and it
makes me even more excited for the
future of this version of the story
since we're completely in Uncharted
Territory for these characters imagine
what that TV show is going to be like it
it's gonna be nothing like any of the
other ones I wish rise of the TMNT had
taken off and gotten the love it
deserved but this movie is a perfect
consolation by bringing in even more
fresh ideas and A Creative Vision for
the franchise unlike all the previous
ones
is it the best Turtles movie
I don't know I'd have to watch it a few
more times but it's definitely the best
animated one
I always get mad at YouTube for not
putting my videos in the subscription
box because people will comment finally
Xavier uploads again after all these
years not knowing three other videos
came out within the last month already
so maybe that stupid Bell icon thing
will help you remember I exist if you
want other ways to support the channel
you can always go hit up that patreon
for early videos and exclusive stuff
because it's just a dollar I'm not
kidding it's only one dollar Isn't that
cool if everyone who watched this video
donated one dollar a month I'd be able
to afford a house for myself so that
would be that would be really cool you
can also check out our merch on T public
or just buy some of my random stuff on
eBay I have a pretty substantial
collection of old toys that are still in
the box in perfect condition so go take
a look in case you find something you
like and lastly since this is a YouTube
video and you probably play fortnite
drop my Creator quote Xavier GM next
time you buy a silly dancer cool
character skin really helps me out
see you next time
[Music]
foreign